what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back with sins of sinister and in
this one we're covering nightcrawlers
which is amazing because the ending of
this is gonna be pretty nuts so here's
the way this works so as you guys know
with the Sims of sinister storyline that
Marvel is basically releasing three
different Comics essentially that show
us what's going on during this 10-year
time period going into the future when
Sinister basically conquers everything
and so what this does is this initially
picks up in the sanctum Saint torm right
of doctor strange and what we end up
having here is in effect Banshee now
this is a version of Banshee that we
haven't really talked about yet and in
fact it's a version of his character
that has been introduced relatively
recently in the Legion of X storyline in
the new era of Marvel Comics X-Men stuff
but the idea behind this is this guy
possesses What's called the spirit of
variance now one of the big questions
that I'm sure people are kind of asking
here is that in this time when sinisters
conquered everything with somebody like
Banshee or even with the character of
Doctor Strange what Steven's strange
doing at the moment that he's not even
in his own sanctum Santorum well the
answer to that is simple guys he is
using an app called Wonder yes he is
time for a brand integration so first
things first I do want to say thank you
to wonder for sponsoring this video and
for those of you all who don't know what
wonder is this is an app that turns
keywords or turns prompts really into
artwork and it's nuts how good this is
because there's no differentiation
between like a human being and like AI
generated art when you use Wonder it's
crazy how advanced it is so what we're
going to do here is I'm going to show
you guys how to use this app I have the
premium version that I paid for but I'm
gonna put a prompt in here and I'm going
to show you all how the whole process
works so we're going to put in I mean we
got to do something comic book related
right I'm literally a come up with
YouTube channel so we're gonna put in
like
Spider-Man
spider Dash man
uh walking
on the moon
on the moon and then we're gonna give
this uh oops we're gonna give this a
cinematic look we're gonna do a three by
two and then we're gonna hit create and
so it's gonna throw us in the queue
right literally it's gonna say it's
queuing up and then it's going to like
literally generate it in front of us
right here
and
it looks awesome oh my God
I love the way this one looks
but literally just like right there
you've just got Spider-Man art you can
literally take this send it out to be
printed and then hang it up in your
house just like that right like
I can't stop somebody snap for me I
can't stop you can do it like
lickety-split right it's really really
cool the way this works so yeah this is
the app guys um again I use this just
for artwork that I'm putting around the
house or if I want to throw something
cool on like Facebook or you know
something along those lines because I'm
old I still use Facebook uh but uh yeah
like this is this is what I'm doing so
make sure you guys go check the link in
the description make sure you guys get
the premium version because again that's
the one that unlocks all the really
really cool stuff but thank you all for
watching let's get back into our video
and talk about nightcrawlers
so back to our discussion here so the
thing about what's going on here is that
we don't exactly know what Stephen
Strange is doing in all seriousness uh
but we do know that with Banshee and
with a spirit of variance there's not a
whole lot that we know here because of
the fact that the spirit of variance was
introduced so recently and then
immediately thrown into this this is
going to be one of those instances where
we see the capabilities of what the
spirit of variance can do and that as
time progresses Marvel will likely build
on it but the spirit of variance was at
one point a spirit of Vengeance and this
is one of the big changes that Marvel's
making to the nature of Ghost Rider the
Ghost Rider Mythos itself that when it
comes to the spirits of Vengeance they
weren't really a collective of beings
that existed out there that instead the
spirit Avengers was more of a concept it
was the General name given to the dark
Persona of a Ghostwriter but the reality
here is that how that Ghost Rider gained
their powers changed from one Ghost
Rider to the next and so what Marvel's
doing here is they're introducing this
idea that the spirits of Vengeance are
more like a spiritual Collective that
exists out there not that dissimilar
from like Cosmic entities but
drastically less powerful seemingly and
that the spirit of variance was at one
point a spirit of Vengeance but unlike
the other spirits of Vengeance it
effectively kind of changed its ways
decided to go a different route and was
more peaceful in nature as opposed to
destructive and this led to the spirits
of Vengeance effectively casting it out
so again this may be one of those things
where it may not necessarily stand the
test of time which is to say in like
five years somebody's gonna get rid of
it and you'll never see her hear from
the spirit of errands again and it'll
kind of go back to just being the
traditional spirit of Vengeance that
exists out there but again you know it's
just a it's a cool little change to see
whether or not it's sticks with a
general audience or whether or not
Marvel keeps it but that's why you see
this different variation of bands here
this different appearance of Banshee now
the cool thing about this is that in the
middle of that while he's here he's
suddenly set upon by What's called the
Legion of the night and this group is
cool and it's one of the coolest things
that I've seen Marvel do in recent years
so one of the things we had talked about
in the sins of sinister one shot which
again and you'll find the playlist down
in the description if you want to get
caught up we're only two videos in so
there really isn't a whole lot of
catching up to do there but one of the
things that we have found out is that
during this 10-year time period dead
Sinister was creating what were
basically Chimera a sort of a merger of
different mutants and their powers that
existed out there but one of the things
we learned beyond that was Sinister sort
of taking over and possessing even
non-mutant beings that were out there
Spider-Man is an example of this and so
what's in effect happened here is that
you have toad you have Sabretooth you
have Spider-Man you've got x-23 Laura
Kinney you have pyro you have people
here right it looks like pixie I'm
pretty sure but you have people here who
have basically been merged with the
powers of Nightcrawler and what this
does is it turns them into sinister's
most deadly assassins now I wouldn't be
surprised if Psy Superior had taken like
X-Men 2 remember like the old
Nightcrawler intro from the X-Men 2 film
if that was his motivation for why this
was happening because that scene in that
movie made Nightcrawler cooler that I
think he'd ever been in the history of
Marvel Comics it was dope to see
Nightcrawler as an assassin jumping
through the Y White House and going
after the president so I'm not surprised
if this was like a major influence for
that but having characters like x23 and
Spider-Man who have been taken over by
the power of sinister and their powers
have been augmented to basically include
the abilities of Nightcrawler where they
can teleport around it's cool because
they're basically everywhere plus the
Legion of the night is just a dope name
let's just say it guys like it's just
ridiculously cool but one of the funny
things about this is that these guys
have been on the hunt for Banshee for
quite some time now this is when we get
this small kind of adjustment to the
capabilities of what Banshee can do that
one of the things that happens here is
that in this fight he used What's called
the scream of change and this is kind of
a differentiation between like the
spirit of variance and like the spirit
of Vengeance the spirit of Vengeance if
we want to go that route and actually
accept that as a thing that it provides
its user with something called the pen
and stair and that's well known in the
Marvel Community among Ghost Rider fans
those of you guys who aren't familiar
with the pen and stair what it does is
that when it's used on someone it forces
them to feel the pain of everyone they
have ever heard over the course of their
life all at one time but with a scream
of change what ends up happening is that
when it's used on x23 it actually breaks
the the hole that Sinister has on x23
and when that happens it actually leads
to Banshee not just using it on x23 but
using it on everybody else and in
essence liberates them from the control
of sinister now one of the things right
off the bat is that we're told this is
not some kind of MacGuffin it's not some
kind of thing where all Banshee has to
do is just get like a really really big
bull horn and just shout into the air
and whole cities will be liberated from
sinister's control one of the things
we're told here is that they've tried
this multiple times on different people
who have been taken over by Sinister and
it doesn't work so for whatever reason
it seemingly works here so it's really
just a way for Spurrier to give us this
explanation of how this team can kind of
come into existence but it's not going
to be this way across the board
unilaterally as far as everyone being
possessed by Sinister on Earth not only
that what ends up happening here is once
this is done Banshee actually teleport
reports and meets with Mother righteous
now again mother righteous was also
introduced in Legion of x one of the
reasons why we kind of skipped over the
first volume of legion of X is because
it's not very important it's really just
kind of establishing what goes on with
Legion himself you don't really see any
like grandiose displays of his power or
anything along those lines it's really
just kind of like here's what Legion and
like some other characters are doing
like at this point in time it's a setup
story it's really all it is volume 2 is
where things get really really cool but
volume one is by no means essential at
least if you're already familiar with
the characters if you don't know
anything about Legion or any of those
characters sure I guess it's essential
to a degree but the thing about this is
that what we find out from mother
righteous is that she's actually meeting
with orbis Stellaris as well as Dr
stasis now these are characters that we
have talked about before we covered
orbit Stellaris and Dr stasis after we
did the sins of sinister one shot and
what we learned is that the Mr Sinister
that we've seen all these years in
Marvel Comics is just one version of him
that he's more or less a clone of the
original Nathaniel Essex that Dr stasis
and orbis Stellaris are the other clones
of sinister right so there were like
three down and one to go we didn't know
who the fourth clone was but as this
conversation happens between them one of
the things we find out here is that the
diamond Sinister is kind of operating
Rogue the other sinisters aren't really
on board with what he's doing per se but
the reality is to step into The Fray and
to somehow become involved it basically
risks them becoming controlled by
Sinister and if that were to happen
there wouldn't really be anybody out
there to effectively stand in the way of
sinister but what mother righteous has
been doing has actually been working on
really manipulating magic and so on and
so forth and trying to find a way to
ultimately end these kind of chimera
experiments of sinister but also working
behind the scenes to find the main base
of operations for sinister where he
basically has the more McTaggart clones
now we talked about that in the last
video that we did where we talked about
how more mctaggart's power was that
every time she died the timeline was
reset and so Sinister himself is the
only one that has possession of the
cloning facility and he has all these
different versions of more mctagon so
that if for some reason his experiment
goes awry he can kill one of the moras
reset time but he'll remember everything
right he'll literally have a kind of
database backup that will show him
everything that's happened in his own
mind he won't recall everything but
having it all in a computer system that
he can just go back and watch it
basically fills in the gap's form so he
can continue his experiment from there
becoming aware of what it was that would
happen like quite literally Sinister
would go to his base of operations and
he would say okay here's why the whole
experiment failed so now I'm going to
kill one of the Maury mctaggart's
Sinister when you watch this you'll
understand everything that went wrong
and you'll know where to make our
Corrections and though he'll just keep
doing that and doing that and doing that
until he has this kind of perfect
timeline where he rules and controls all
so having like Dr stasis and having
Orvis Stellaris despite the fact that
they are clones of the original Sinister
just like the Sinister with a diamond on
his head they're actively trying to work
against him while not being overly
obvious about the fact that they're
trying to work against him but the issue
of mother righteous kind of casting
aside some of these spells actually runs
in the way of what Dr stasis was doing
while he was working with orcas again
the organization that normally would
stand against mutant populations but at
this point is trying to find a way to
defeat Sinister and one of the things he
says here is that orcas commission that
hex and while it lasted Sinister was
unable to exploit some of the most
dangerous Bloodlines now he's using the
Nightcrawler strain to build his hit
squats so to a degree while orcas is not
mutant friendly and orcas is the
organization that exists out there right
now trying to bring down the mutant
population the truth about it is that
they're standing against Sinister and
before Mother righteous had gotten
involved and kind of destroyed the hex
that was used by orcas that protected
these different uh really more advanced
Bloodlines from sinister's control
people like Nightcrawler for example
that once he did that she more or less
screwed everything up but she more or
less kind of torpedoed what orcas was
doing and that's how we have the Legion
of the night in the first place and so
one of the things that this really
picked up on here by Dr stasis is that
like the accent of mother righteous
which judging by the way that it's
spelled or at least pronunciation Beyond
based on the way that it's spelled it
sounds like uh was it Cockney English
but one of the things that goes on is
that she basically reveals she's the
fourth Sinister now if I'm a betting man
to be honest with you guys I don't think
this was the intention of Marvel which
is why I'm not making a great big huge
scene out of it otherwise it would have
been like I know she takes off her mask
and it turns out she's the four Sinister
there's a reason why I'm not doing that
because I don't think that was actually
supposed to be the case I think this is
what Marvel's doing because of the sins
of sinister event but the reality here
is that mother righteous doesn't have
enough history or even enough
significance in Marvel Comics for it to
actually matter right it's one of those
things where it's kind of like I mean
it's cool I guess whatever but it feels
more shoehorned in right in order to
like bolster the popularity of a
character that's just not that popular
in Marvel it would have been cooler if
it had turned out that like apocalypse
return and he's like one of the
sinisters or something along those lines
right by whatever Manner and whatever
means they want to make that happen it
would have been cool if that was the
case right somebody with a long-standing
bit of history that under normal
circumstances you never would have
expected to be a bad guy but has been
manipulating things behind the scenes
the whole time kind of like a Marvel or
I'm sorry a mutant version of like
Captain America during secret secret
Empire right but once this move is made
and once these other sinisters realize
that mother righteous is basically
trying to take them out because she is
in effect a good guy she's trying to
eliminate all the different versions of
sinister and just sort of go from there
you end up having doctor stasis that
makes this move while orbis Stellaris
watches all of it unfold and where he
does recall or at least use some of his
own forces to try to take them out
that's when you end up having the Legion
of the night who are now liberated and
operating under mother righteous who
show up and immediately attack Dr stasis
and so this guy ultimately ends up just
going the way of the dodo right that's
quite literally it and it's done in one
of the coolest ways ever because x-23
with a Nightcrawler abilities she has a
claw that comes out of her tail and this
is one of those things I didn't know I
needed this until I saw it this is dope
and I'm really really hoping this
version of x23 somehow survives the
whole sins of sinister timeline and in
up in the main Marvel Universe because I
gotta tell you guys man x23 Laura Kinney
with the powers of Nightcrawler and like
an adamantium claw in her tail that's
pretty badass and I'm really hoping that
this stays
I really really do and so following the
defeat of Dr stasis basically uh mother
righteous has this kind of conversation
with orbis Stellaris where he literally
reveals I'm the one who stole the
cloning facility of sinister and I have
it in the world form it's a nigh
impregnable place you can't suddenly
just go in there so if you kill me
you'll never be able to access the
cleaning facility of sinister it'll be
gone forever right it'll literally
disappear for all time and we'll be
stuck in this timeline so either you can
stay out of my way and I'll give you
safe patches through my realm if that's
what you need or you can try to attack
me possibly even kill me and then we're
trapped in this reality until whenever
this timeline comes to a conclusion and
so mother righteous ultimately lets him
go which is really the smartest move to
make more so than that what she also
intends to do is to bolster her forces
and so the intention of really just the
Legion of the night alongside Banshee
being there is one part to try to find a
way to bolster their forces by freeing
other individuals whether it's because
these this kind of freed Legion of the
night wakes other people up or because
it's the powers of the spirit of
variance wait picking other people up
much like he woke up the Legion of the
night ultimately it doesn't necessarily
work of course it is a bit of a heist to
a degree where they're looking to steal
you know particular things they do end
up stealing a magical book which is not
the dark hole per se but it is a book
that allows mother righteous to
manipulate uh spells to a degree but the
bigger part of this is they have to find
a way to see if they can get into the
get into the the world form and so using
a kind of magical enchantment along with
the Spider-Man Nightcrawler merger that
basically is willing to sacrifice his
life because of the fact that for some
reason it's not fully explained those
individuals who are not mutants but are
possessed by Sinister they can't stay
freed for too long that the powers of
Banshee only work for so long and then
they'll eventually wear off and
Spider-Man would ultimately fall back
under the control of sinister and in
fact he says as much right I can feel
those forces I can feel the voice of
sinister creeping back in again it's
only a matter of time before I succumb
to his control and then I ultimately try
to kill all of you guys which for the
most part Spider-Man with the powers of
Nightcrawler could he's the perfect
assassin but with Peter Parker sacrifice
pricing his life and with the team now
consisting of people like Colossus as
well as looks like a younger pixie maybe
magic is kind of weird kind of hard to
tell but with the team's roster being
bolstered by like one or two people that
Peter's life is sacrificed when he
literally tries to teleport into the
world form and ultimately perishes in
the conflict right perishes during that
time because he can't necessarily break
through but what mother righteous
realizes is that the force field is not
impregnable that given the right level
of power it can be broken through and so
what she does is she sends the rest of
the team on what is in effect a kind of
scavenger hunt right to basically steal
various magical artifacts that exist out
there these magical artifacts consist of
things like the dark hold right it looks
that looks like the uh The Siege
perilous I'm not 100 sure if it is if I
remember correctly it is the hammer of
Thor the eye of agamoto of doctor
strange and for those who were
eagle-eyed enough one of the helmets of
the black priest from Jonathan Hickman's
Avengers and New Avengers run right the
ability to manipulate magical words it's
like the black priests were insane
mainly powerful they were able to like
wipe out whole worlds and different
things like that and Destroy entire
groups of Avengers in one Fell Swoop it
was nuts but this was basically some of
the most powerful magical artifacts in
existence across all of Marvel Comics
that are being used and being brought
together by mother righteous for the
purpose of taking down the world Farm
These are powers that in some ways rival
the abilities of cosmic entities so with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end thank you all for
watching make sure you check out wonder
and I will catch you all later
peace